the NBA draft is coming up on Thursday a
process dating back to 1947 where teams
can sign up new players mostly from the
U.S college system but some straight
from high school and international
leagues as well quite often the number
one pick goes on to have a great career
Shaquille O'Neal Kyrie Irving Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar and Magic Johnson were all
first picks as was LeBron James in 2003
signed up by the Cleveland Cavaliers at
just 18 the high schooler was branded
the chosen one but going number one
isn't everything it's fair to say Kobe
Bryant had a pretty good career another
school pick he went number 13 in the
1996 draft going on to win five
championships Nicola jokic just won the
NBA title this year he was drafted
number 41 by the Denver Nuggets in 2014
the lowest pick ever to go on to be
named MVP in the finals 2021 Champion
Giannis antetokom who was at first pick
either he was 15th in 2013 Frenchman
Tony Parker won the NBA trophy four
times but was a originally picked number
28 in 2001 by the San Antonio Spurs
11-time NBA champion Bill Russell no one
has more titles than him he was second
pick way back in 1956 and perhaps the
most famous player ever Michael Jordan
was drafted number three by the Chicago
Bulls from North Carolina in 1984. so
watch out for the number one pick for
sure on Thursday night but remember it's
still a long way to go before they
become an all-time great